biden took a slightly different tone
today didn't want to answer any
questions and he called our own peter
ducey a stupid son of a [ __ ] really
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
stupid son of a [ __ ] mr unity strikes
again in all seriousness joe biden
really shouldn't be casting stones from
an extremely extremely fragile glass
house here with reaction fox news white
house correspondent peter ducey has an
update on the story first what was your
reaction
um
words don't matter to me i remember
during the trump years everybody would
feign the vapors oh the president said
this i think i know you pretty well you
have you're a pretty tough guy
what was your reaction initially when
you heard what happened
my reaction sean was delayed because as
you can see in that clip the biden staff
were ushering us out they were telling
us okay thank you time to go and you can
see right there that people are just
starting to move towards the door myself
included it wasn't until we went to the
basement and then outside and then back
to the press room that somebody said hey
did you hear what the president said
about you i said no what did he say so
he called you a stupid sob and i was
thinking that
i did not hear that and i went
downstairs and i uh opened up my phone
and uh he did and so i my response was
delayed
but but sean and we have some news
tonight
uh after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
uh within about an hour of that exchange
he called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we went back and forth and we were
talking about i
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always going to try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and uh he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president so
i'll keep doing it
all right i want to be your negotiator
here and i would like to negotiate a
20-minute sit-down with you and biden
one-on-one i think that would be
you know
i'm a christian i believe in forgiveness
okay did he apologize
uh he cleared the air and i appreciate
it we had a nice call
he's that's not an answer did he
apologize that doesn't sound like an
apology he he said it's nothing personal
pal and i told him that i appreciated
him reaching out hey hey sean uh the
world is on the brink of like world war
three right now
with all this stuff going on i
appreciate that the president took a
couple minutes out this evening while he
was still at the desk to give me a call
and clearly at least he called you
powell but you know what i don't need
anybody to apologize to me uh he can
call me whatever he wants as long as it
gets him talking and today you know you
played some of the bit with jen saki and
i i went in there with two pages of
questions about crime i actually still
have them right here they've been rolled
up in my pocket
two pages of crime questions that i
didn't get in at the press conference
last week that two hour press conference
and so i'm in there and i'm looking okay
if he takes questions what's it gonna be
but he said i'm not gonna take questions
about anything off topic so i'm thinking
okay well uh the topic is inflation hey
over here uh and then it took like five
minutes but i later heard what he said i
wan i think the president should
apologize by giving you 20 minutes
uninterrupted one-on-one interview and
that
and first gen sake she owes you 20
minutes too i'm trying to negotiate on
your behalf hey they keep calling on us
at the briefing and the president said
nothing personal pal and so i i think
that's enough that's enough
come on man so we can move on
we can now move forward there will be
years uh three to seven years
of opportunities to ask him uh about
different stuff we're proud of the good
work you're doing keep it up uh and
if
i think it's a badge of honor myself so
uh if i'm your dad i'm very proud of you
tonight anyway great job peter
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else